d'habitude le marché notre dame à
versailles ressemble à ça mais
aujourd'hui avec la situation sanitaire
les seuls stand autorisées se trouve
devant les différentes entrées des
halles depuis le 17 avril 34 commerce
sont présents en matinée des gens sont
vraiment content vraiment son sens que
ça fait du bien à beaucoup de gens de
ressortir de revoir les commerçants
c'est ça fait partie du quotidien de
chaque versailles et de venir sur le
marché et là de retrouver un petit peu
ça je pense que ça redonne un petit peu
de baume au coeur du moral avoir du
poisson frais à voir le caviste ça c'est
des choses qui sont importantes
on a une satisfaction également de
retrouver nos commerçants habituels ça
amène voilà une vie important de
quartier d'avoir même réouverte marchés
partiellement pour cette réouverture la
ville a obtenu une dérogation du préfet
des yvelines des tables ont été disposés
pour éviter tout contact avec les
clients les commerçants respectent
également les règles sanitaires
on a tous des masques on a des visières
aussi pour ceux qui travaillent sur
l'extérieur et
bon on a les gels on a les gones et
voilà moi la sécurité des clients et
puis on a on a mis des fromages sous
vide pour que justement on n'est pas de
trop de deux gestes a touché les
fromages en plus de cette réouverture
partielle des halles la municipalité a
pris plusieurs mesures en faveur des
commerçants pour faire face à la crise
lorsque nous sommes propriétaires des
locaux nous ne faisons pas à payer les
loyers aux commerçants pendant la durée
ou une soupe ans d'activité deuxième
mesure c'est que nous faisons pas payer
les droits de terrasses et enfin nous
avons distribué des masques aux
commerçants qui sont ouverts parce que
ce sont des basques dits chirurgicaux
des bases de qualité et ça permet aux
commerçants ouverts de se protéger et de
protéger leur clientèle la commune
estime la perte de recettes lié aux
annulations des loyers des commerçants à
environ 500000 euros